[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter labelle
well it didn't take long days after the
putin biden summit the uk
committed some very undiplomatic acts in
the black sea
we'll tell you why also after heated
debate
the eu has proven unable to find a
unified voice
to engage russia whose fault is that
[Music]
to discuss these issues and more i'm
joined by my guest marcus papadopoulos
in london he's a historian
analyst and author of the new book arise
rossia the return
of russia to world politics and in
budapest we cross to george samueli he
is a podcaster at the gaggle
which can be found on youtube rumble and
locals
all right gentlemen crosstalk rules in
effect that means you can jump in
anytime you want and i always appreciate
it
okay let's go to london first marcus can
you explain to me what the uk
is doing in the black sea and all of
their gobbly
explanations for their um intrusion
um on territory waters of russia that
russia claims i know that the
the uk does not recognize crimea as part
of um ukraine but they
uh as far as russia and but you know
they they they have two alt
two different explanations it's
ukrainian waters it's international
waters what is it and what are they
doing and
it's very un-diplomatic are they looking
for a provocation go ahead marcus
well the infamous incident in russian
maritime waters
adjacent to the crimean peninsula was
evidently
a staged provocation by both britain
and america and i say america
as well because london and washington
act in unison
on the international stage and that is
especially the case
when it comes to russia and this staged
provocation was both foolhardy
and exceedingly dangerous now
the question is why did london
and washington orchestrate this
provocation
of russia well i cannot believe
that the americans and the british
seriously
wish to goad russia into a military
confrontation with the west
because the americans and the british
know as we
know that a military conflict with
russia would
rapidly would rapidly escalate into a
nuclear
exchange so it is my opinion that the
reason why the british and the americans
staged this provocation was to portray
russia as an aggressive and dangerous
force which warrants the increase
in nato's presence on the russian border
in terms of
surgery and weaponry and also it
warrants the case for ukraine to be
admitted into the ranks
of nato the british government's
official line
that they do not recognize the crimea as
part of russia and therefore
hms defender the royal navy shock ship
involved in the incident
was in ukrainian waters is of is an
illogical
and quite simply uh untenable argument
to make
because if the if that argument was
applied across the world
then other countries in the world could
no longer recognize
british jurisdiction over the north or
northern ireland
or british jurisdiction over the
malvinas or the falkland islands
or indeed british jurisdiction over the
chagos
islands so the real reason was to goad
russia
to portray russia in a very negative
dangerous
way to justify nato's increasing
and dangerous presence on the russian
border and also
to increase the uh case for ukraine to
be admitted into
nato you know george we we all know that
um the
the uh i guess it's annual sea breeze um
uh um exercises are planned for this
week here
was this a trial balloon to see what the
reaction is going to be
also um we have with this um uh a
british ship
uh getting so close to a russian
sovereign um
border uh with uh uh on the crimea in
the black sea
is that it was a reconnaissance uh
mission as well seeing what kind of
defenses are there
so i mean there's provocation written
all over this go ahead
yes there was a provocation and uh and
without question
it is about um trying to uh first
humiliate russia
and to mobilize nato
into uh you know more more expenditure
more reasons for existence more
expansion
and but i think also there is a domestic
aspect to it which is that
i mean the boris johnson government is
uh is in hopeless uh
tatters where we have um its minister
matt hancock uh
resigning um this weekend um over
a absurd uh situation where he was
violating his own um
uh coveted restrictions um we we
and we have johnson counting his uh
supposedly uh global britain whereby
britain now has a major
world power and has a a role to play in
the world
well of course it is complete nonsense
because britain
is not a serious player on the world
stage
and what britain did in uh
in promoting russia was clearly
absolutely ludicrous
uh just on its face because of the the
the rationales that it has come up with
such as oh well uh this was innocent
passage
which even when you look at it that just
in terms of what the u.n
convention on the law of the sea says an
innocent passage does not apply
to a warship that is passing through
territorial waters
locked and loaded and disengaged in a
propaganda exercise and johnson openly
said this is a propaganda exercise to
show
that these waters don't belong to russia
but belong to ukraine so it was a
propaganda exercise
and moreover russia had already
explicitly stated in april of this year
that there is to be no innocent passage
uh
in crimea that's it actually they stated
it in april
so this was months before johnson comes
along with this nonsense that
oh this was an innocent passage we were
just going from a to b
so i i you know going back to your
original question so you know
i think britain is trying to throw its
weight around in the world
but is making itself up into an absolute
laughing stock
and unfortunately because britain
doesn't have a proper
opposition i mean where is the labor
party uh there's no one really
holding johnson's feet to the fire as to
why exactly is he getting
britain involved potentially into a very
serious military conflict with the
nuclear power
yeah and marcus at the end of the day i
mean it was an attempt to humiliate
russia but it was the uk
that was humiliated it i mean this was a
self-inflicted
wound i mean they ran they they they
turned around and ran away
okay and they and of course in the media
coverage of it you know
um russia there was a um a warning shot
there were planes involved and they the
as far as i understand the uk government
denied all of it but none of that is
true it actually all happened
go ahead marcus peter first of all i
must say this
i beseech people to not dismiss
britain in the world who is at the heart
along with the americans of the banking
of the global banking system and the
global
financial system britain in particular
specifically
the city of london britain is an
exceptionally
powerful global player in the world do
not
power just one minute i think if i could
interpret george's words and he can jump
in obviously too
i mean the the uk is making itself
relevant diplomatically militarily on
the coattails of the united states which
i want to talk about a little bit later
here i think that's the context here
right
i mean i'm no one's dismissing the city
of london okay
but i mean of course to use your own
words they never would have done this
that the americans hadn't agreed
yes uh absolutely the americans provide
the military muslims
george we'll get you ahead yeah yes i
mean indeed the british
the americans provide the military
muscle but of course here traditionally
britain is at the heart of the global
financial and banking
system now as regards to nato well
i believe peter that nato expansion into
eastern europe has come
to a halt perhaps nato will expand into
southeastern
europe specifically serbia and bosnia
but as regards eastern europe
it has come to an end why do i say that
because the kremlin will use all means
at its disposal and i mean
all means at its disposal to ensure that
ukraine is never
admitted into the ranks of nato
but i believe that hms defender being
deployed into russian maritime waters
does show that the british and the
americans feel
emboldened because britain never
recognized the baltic states of estonia
latvia and lithuania
as part of the soviet union yet
nonetheless london
never violated soviet maritime waters
adjacent to the baltic states and let me
add this one other point peter
the british ruling elite instead of
deploying the royal
navy to the black sea to goad russia
should actually deploy the royal navy in
full strength to the english channel
to defend england from illegal
immigrants crossing on a daily basis
from kelly if they care about the
british people
that is where they would deploy the
royal navy to well
along on this program i've said nato
really does have an important mission
only one single one
defend europe and immigration is one of
an anti-terrorism in another
but those are way down on the list
apparently george you want to jump in go
ahead
yes i know i i don't disagree with
marcus about the key
uh role of uh british uh finance
um in in the in the world um
but as a military power britain is
insignificant i mean we've seen how
uh feebly uh britain has fought in
recent years i mean it's
it's military performance and iraq was a
joke
so any attempt by britain in ukraine
or uh in the black sea to get itself
into some sort of
a military uh conflict with russia would
end in a complete debacle
for britain i mean this is and that's i
think very different from the united
states i mean united states is a serious
military force
uh great britain is not a serious
military force and that's why i think
uh johnson's idea that uh great britain
is
this uh global britain is as a some sort
of a major power in the world
is uh completely uh misconceived
okay okay we're rapidly running this
part of the program i want to ask you
both
of the same question first of mark is
here is
you know you can interpret the the
recent um um
putin biden um summit in many different
ways and george and i have done it on a
different
venue on our gaggle but i mean is is
this undermining
any possibility of kind of lowering
tensions because that's one
interpretation you can take from the
summit marcus first then i'll go to
george go ahead real quick no i don't
believe that
if there is um to be an improvement
in relations between russia and the west
then the ball
so to speak is firm in the court of the
west the west uh nato needs to withdraw
its presence from the russian border the
americans need to pledge
in writing that ukraine moldova and
georgia
will not be admitted into the ranks of
nato and also the americans need to
dismantle
their missile defense system in poland
and romania
unless that happens there will be no
improvement in relations between western
russia
your answer george go ahead yeah no i i
think that's uh
the right i don't think there's any real
prospect of improvement of relations
with russia
uh unless nato makes uh significant
changes nato will not make
uh significant changes um but and i
and i think there are countries such as
great britain
that thrive on uh tension with russia it
elevates
their significance and suddenly you can
play around being the sort of the big
uh player in on the world stage so uh
johnson certainly does not want any kind
of a dayton because then
you know his role in the world uh is
much diminished oh and they taunt it
it's not a money maker is it gentlemen
it's not all right i'm going to jump in
here we're going to go to a short break
after that short break we'll continue
our discussion on some
important new news
[Music]
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lovell
this is the home edition
to remind you we're discussing some real
news
[Music]
okay gentlemen let's change gears let's
go let me go back to george and budapest
well you know the there's this trobe out
there that
the russians are always trying to divide
uh member states of the eu
conquering divide and all that but when
the eu
gets together on the back of us a strong
suggestion from
the german chancellor and the french
president to start a
dialogue on specific issues with russia
they put it to the vote and you know
what happened
no consensus here the russians are left
who do we talk to you want to talk who
do we talk to
and that's the the that's where we stand
right now how do you see that george
because it looks like
you know the the germans and the french
want to move forward but of course it's
the the polls in the baltic states that
uh do not want to is
actually want more sanctions i mean this
is just
uh turning the eu's policy towards
russia into a pretzel
go ahead george yes well it's the poland
of the baltic states
but it's also um joseph burrell the
eu foreign minister so to speak remember
he was tasked by the
uh eu council to come up with a working
paper as to
future eu relations with russia
precisely because
france germany you know probably italy
uh want a working relationship with
russia
and then burrell comes up with this
ridiculous uh
paper about a week 10 days ago
in which he talks about constrained uh
and uh you know push back and and engage
with russia
engage only on issues that matter to the
eu not on anything that might
matter to russia so that's borrel uh who
seems to be completely stuck in this uh
mindset of uh russia this malevolent
force
so you know you've got what what is
really going on in the eu
the serious powers in the year which is
france german in italy
say we have to return to what what was
the status quo ante before 2014
a working partnership with russia and
then you've got the eu bureaucracy the
name of
burrell and and then you've got the
baltics and uh
and poland who just want more sanctions
and the end result is
well we're going to have more sanctions
and that's that's what
the eu's position now is we're going to
be working towards uh developing more
sanctions
no one quite knows what about what but
rest assured
more sanctions are needed you know
marcus i'm glad that
george brought up 2014 because because
that's of course on the back of the
illegal
uh forced regime change in um ukraine
which for some reason is blamed on
russia
um um and so we have this you know we
have um
going on seven years now um why should
the russians really particularly care
i mean if you don't want to sit down and
talk i mean why should they keep waiting
around
i mean this has been my position for a
long time if you don't want to parlay
then get along get on with your life
we'll get out and get on with ours we
live in the same neighborhood but if you
don't want to be
good neighborly then what's the point
what why should russia
have to reach out the ball is in
europe's court okay
and they need that relationship with
russia russia
needs a relationship with europe less
and less with every passing day that's
my contention at least
go ahead marcus prior to eu expansion
into the
baltic states into eastern europe and
into southeastern europe
the eu truly was a force to be
reckoned with it was an exceptionally
affluent
elite club whose members with the
exception of greece and portugal
made an immense amount of money however
the eu's leadership um
overstretched themselves when they
admitted the baltic states
eastern europe and southeastern europe
into the ranks
of the eu they never considered what the
consequences
potential consequences could be for
having
countries such as poland and the baltic
states inside
of the eu and now today we
see a farcical situation in which
a minority of members of the eu
are holding to ransom the rest of the eu
visa v russia the eu
and i mean specifically the major
countries uh france
germany but also italy and spain and
then others such as
hungary and greece want to have better
relations with russia in fact they want
to go back
to how relations were prior to the coup
in kiev
in february of 2014 but the european
union
is handicapped it is handicapped because
of the behavior of poland and the baltic
states
and i don't see how paris and berlin can
actually get
around that now because yes the french
and the germans
have very strong financial relations
with russia but so also to
spain and um and italy in particular
the agricultural sectors in spain and
italy are no longer to are no longer
able to export
their produce to the russian federation
as they once were prior to the eu
sanctions
on russia so the eu or the leadership of
the eu
only has itself to blame by having
expanded into
parts of europe which were always going
to be problematic they did not
strategically plan
for countries such as poland and the
baltic states and now as i said moments
ago
the eu in regard to its relationship
with russia has become
handicapped because poland and the
baltic states
do not wish there to be any improvements
between the eu
and russia why because they
are constantly portraying russia as a
threat
to the whole of europe and thereby they
are receiving
even more financial assistance from
america and also
even more soldiery and weaponry of nato
on their respective territories
george so so obviously the eu isn't
making any headway here
i mean what are the benefits that
countries like poland and the baltic
republics garner from this position
because i
simply don't see any it's just kind of
spike
and they want to spike for historical
cultural
or ideological reasons the entire block
suffers
and as i say every time i do crosstalk
the world is moving on europe if you
want to tread water
go right ahead because everybody else is
moving forward
i mean this is just the most ridiculous
situation to have it's like
dealing with children in a cafeteria go
ahead yes it is
uh and uh i mean their calculation is
well
we'll we will have washington in our
corner the united states
will be there for us but you know
we know about the united states the
united states doesn't shell out money
unless there's something really big in
it for the united states
um and i mean you remember when uh trump
said okay well we're gonna move uh
troops out of um germany and move them
into poland
and then they say oh great you know
we'll call it fort trump and everything
but it never materialized i mean as
always happens with these american
promises they never really materialized
and and it's true as marcus said which
is that
uh there was a moment in history when
the eu
was kind of a serious uh third force
uh you know you had the hawkish very
russophobic uh
united states uh and then you had the eu
which uh you know had good relations
with america but also
sought a partnership uh with russia
um and you know much of the sort of the
brexiteer
energy uh in the uk came from
anguished uh uh political figures and
said oh my god
this eu that we're members of it's going
to become anti-american and he's going
to become neutralist and he's going to
be pro-russian
we can't be a part of this because we
have to maintain this uh
this transatlantic uh alliance but of
course
it hasn't happened and then this eu now
is in this ludicrous position it's like
even more hawkish
if anything than the united states yeah
yeah
and it's very interesting with the with
since um uh brexit here we have
obviously the uk out and now they've
gone
it's almost kind of like um the uk is
kind of the
um um
i can't find them right like america's
help around the world we discussed in
the first part of the program
going into the black sea maybe doing it
for the america showing their value
okay um because their influence
obviously over the eu
at least diplomatically is non-existent
anymore so i mean
and now we we have a small number of
countries within the eu dictating the
direction of it
and um and i would say that the the the
uk's role is is more symbolic than
anything else i mean
the symbolism is really humiliating
every step of the way here and then you
have paralysis in europe so again i
repeat my position why should the
russians particularly care if they
what they need to do is counter nato the
rest of it is a internal
intra pan-european problem go ahead
marcus
what is lamentable peter is when
britain finally withdrew from the
european
union there was and perhaps there still
is a minuscule window of opportunity
for an improvement between the european
union
and russia because whilst britain was in
the eu countries such as france
and germany would come under more and
more
pressure indirectly from america
via britain however we have seen
no improvement in relations between the
eu and russia indeed i would go as far
to say
that relations have deteriorated even
further
so far in 2021 and we have to ask the
question
why well i think to a very large extent
it comes down to the immense influence
that washington exerts inside of the
european
union not just economic but also
militarily why because most
of the european union member states are
also
crucially members of nato
and if met countries are members of nato
then that provides america with a
tremendous amount
of influence over the decision-making uh
process in those respective countries
but also
in a block and i'm talking about the
european union as a whole
so i believe that whilst paris and
berlin
sincerely want to have dialogue with
russia sincerely want to be able to
trade properly
with russia again they are hamstrung
by the very fact that they are both
members of nato and because they are not
able to eliminate american influence
inside of the european union
finish off with torture i mean remember
during trump you know
trump was disregarding or disrespecting
allies
but actually what we have under biden
which is continuation of other
administrations
the more melees inside the european
union the better
okay i mean what a way to treat your
allies okay whether they're in
they have a form of paralysis they can't
even make their own foreign policy and
of course i agree with marcus
it works to washington's advantage
you're great allies they're in paralysis
you know what a
what a bizarre way of looking at the
world finish up forest george
yes that's right if remember uh trump's
line was
oh my god we're doing all this for
europe's and they're such
ungrateful people you know they don't
you know they don't realize all the
wonderful things that we're doing for
them
and so and they're stabbing us in the
back and then when macron
uh suggested well maybe there should be
a european security and
defense identity what are you out of
your mind no there is only one
path forward security and defense nato
um so and this has always been the
american thing
all right jordan sorry i have to jump in
here we've run out of time i want to
thank my guests in london and budapest
and i think our viewers for watching us
here at rp see you next time remember
[Music]
crosstalks